britney spears but in just six days
brittany will take center stage
in court
the thing with britney spears is as we
all know she's very unpredictable
i love freedom i love independence
brittany is known to go off script and
that could very well happen here
i'm taking a break right now because um
i'm enjoying myself
who knows will brittany blast her father
break down or call for an end to her
conservatorship
this conservative ship has got to go
it's all been building up to next
wednesday and the singer's big day in
court
this is a really big deal because we've
heard britney spears speak out on social
media
am i okay yes i'm totally fine but this
is the first time we're going to hear
her speaking out in court
here's what we know about britney taking
the stand the 39 year old will appear
remotely
perhaps from home or her attorney's
office officials cite covet protocols
for the virtual appearance
right now it's unclear if there will be
a video feed of britney in addition to
her live audio
i don't like to be tied down i like to
travel as for brittany's courtroom
strategy
well experts say she should choose her
words wisely
if i was working with britney spears i
would say let's keep this short
let's keep it to the point let's speak
from the heart let's not get into the
legal nitty-gritty
and even though britt won't be there in
person court officials are bracing for a
crowd
anxious to hear her side there will be
limited seating
inside the la courtroom an overflow
courtroom and a strict
no cameras allowed policy so just what
is britney's goal in all of this
we think she's most likely going to ask
for her father to be removed from the
conservatorship
jamie spears who has partial control of
brittany's finances
has been her co-conservator since her
infamous 2008 public meltdown
last year brittany said through her
attorney that she was afraid of her dad
and would not perform again as long as
he was part of the conservatorship
this is a tense relationship it's
documented she's wanted him off for a
while
so i think her goal in the status
hearing and the reason why she wants to
speak out is so the judge can hear from
her
what she wants in this so she has a
[Music]
voice